so really quick guys let me apologize
for this review being kind of late I'm
sorry about that had some things get in
the way of me posting it I have a huge
metal gear fan
the very first Metal Gear Solid game
really inspired me when I first played
this game for PlayStation 1 I beat it in
a few days
and then literally the very next day I
went back and beated a second time all
in one day virtually in one sitting
taking various bathroom breaks and food
breaks but this game changed the way I
viewed video games because up until then
I view them as some fun entertainment
when I played this game I mean there was
such a story behind it there was
characters that you really felt for it
was almost like a cinematic experience
it wasn't just a fun game it was a great
story and this really changed my entire
opinion on video games in general which
is why I'm a huge metal gear fan so when
I heard about Metal Gear Rising I was
optimistic well worried because it's not
stealth at all it has nothing to do with
stealth I mean this game is 100% hack
and slash take your sword to everyone
and see if you can cut him up into
little pieces and how quick can you
actually do it there's no there's no
stealth of this game in fact there's a
few times in this game where your
friends are like hey Ryan once you try
to sneak past these guards and you try
yes you're not sneaking past anyone
you're going to cut him up into little
pieces this game follows the character
of Ryden who to many fans dismay was
actually the main character of Metal
Gear Solid 2 and showed up quite often
in middle Gear Solid 4 and he was
awesome in Metal Gear 4 he really was
great and I didn't mind him so much in
to either I got used to him and I
enjoyed him as a character here he gets
a fantastic remodeling as a character
largely based off of who he was in metal
gear for this really hardcore guy he's
basically like a Clint Eastwood type
killer he doesn't take names he just
goes around that sword and if anyone's
in his way they're getting cut up and he
is awesome in this game he's one of the
coolest protagonists I have taken
control of in a game in a very long time
he is great they did such a good job and
making him a really interesting and
entertaining character and I got into
his life and he was just so much fun to
play there's a kind of convoluted plot
involving this company that wants to
turn children's body parts into cyborgs
body parts and all these children are
basically being turned into cyborgs
against their will
Ryden has to basically stop this from
happening and there's all these
humongous bosses in the way and this
game has quite a bit of boss battles it
really does and lots of robots cyborgs
reminded me a lot of a ghost in the
shell' type field this game really had a
ghost in the shell' vibe to it for sure
and I gotta say that despite my worries
I had a lot of fun with this game it had
fantastic graphics a really great
musical score with really good rock
music in there good voice acting
extremely addictive gameplay and some of
the best all-out button-mashing hacking
slashing I have experienced after I beat
this game I actually went back and
played many of the levels again which is
very rare for me because usually I'm
like okay I beat the game and it's good
and I'll play it maybe a year or
something when I feel like it again no I
went right back
I started playing all the tutorial
missions again just because I wanted to
go around with that awesome sword and
cut up more robots this game isn't
entirely directed by Hideo Kojima the
mastermind behind Metal Gear Solid but
he was definitely involved with this
game and you can really feel it in a lot
of specific places in particular his
sense of humor is 100% still in this
game he has that really twisted side
where you're like where these jokes even
coming from this is great scene where he
has to go down into the sewers he finds
a kid in the sewer now ride ins a ninja
okay he's a ninja in the sewer now what
does the kid say when he sees ride and
cutting up a bunch of people the kid
screams cowabunga a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles joke inside Metal Gear Solid
that's awesome there are a few aspects
to the game's control that got a little
annoying from time to time like for
instance there's kind of a batman arkham
asylum
esque feature to this game where if you
press up on the d-pad you get this like
AR sensor display look where you can see
body heat signatures and everything kind
of like in Batman Arkham Asylum the
annoying thing about that is if you
decide to run during that sequence or
use your sword in any way it
automatically goes away and you can't
use it anymore you can only use it if
you're standing completely still or
walking slowly which is kind of annoying
I did get on my nerves a little bit and
I wish that you could actually keep that
on whenever you wanted to because I
would have helped a lot with the stealth
areas of the game a thing about the
sword as well it
surely everything in this game is
cuttable except for like stairs and
things that you need to progress or
walls or whatever anything you may see
lying around lamp post boxes trees fire
hydrants anything
cars anything can be cut up in this game
and I literally would just find myself
just cutting up random stuff just to
watch the pieces fly so much fun to just
be riding in this game also you get a
really cool side character who doesn't
get too involved with the story which is
great but he's there when when he's
there he's awesome he's a robot
character called wolf and he's
essentially a cyborg wolf but he goes
ahead of you throughout the lands scouts
out the areas and then connects with you
through codec to tell you what you need
to do and where you need to find and I
really liked his character he was funny
like ridin would say a very sarcastic
comment and wolf would have just a
straightforward cyborg answer for and
they got pretty funny and I enjoyed that
speaking of supporting characters you
are in connection with various people
through your codec throughout this game
and whereas in the previous Metal Gear
games I really enjoyed almost all the
characters you were in connection with
through your codec in this game I found
myself not really caring about them and
barely talking to them at all because
they just weren't interesting as people
they weren't really necessary to
progress in the game so much they'll
give you hints from time to time but for
the most part I was let down by the
supporting characters in this game and
that was really my biggest problem I
think with the game was the supporting
characters in the overall story one of
the things I really did enjoy about the
story though is there's a great
underlying theme in the game does ride
and enjoy killing or is he just doing it
because he knows it's the right thing he
has to do at this time
and you really get to see that conflict
with him a lot and he battles with that
between being ridin or being his other
persona Jack the Ripper who he was known
as for a while as this dreadful killer
who could just mutilate anyone in his
path that was a really strong part of
this game for sure now some aspects of
the control have a lot of getting used
to namely parrying or blocking someone's
attack with your sword in most games
it's a button if it's a fight game you
just kind of hold back in the opposite
direction the character in this game you
have to press square if you're on the
ps3 and hit the directional stick in the
direction of the attack and it is very
sensitive and it takes a lot of getting
used to and it could be rather annoying
sometimes a little difficult to master
that also the boss battles in this game
are entertaining and fun
the very
last one is one of the hardest boss
battles I have ever had it literally
took me like I don't know 3540 continues
I was raging mad by the end of that
battle he has an absurd amount of health
and he can recharge his health and I was
just pretty mad I actually almost didn't
finish the game after like 30 tries I'm
done I I'm just gonna watch this footage
on YouTube or something I'm done but I
give it a few more tries and I
eventually mastered his patterns and
everything and I beat it but I'm telling
you that boss is challenging and you
will hate him but when you beat him you
will be very happy trust me
all in all Metal Gear Rising is a
surprisingly fun game I had a great time
with this game it looks fantastic it
sounds fantastic some of the story
elements are a little weak but I had a
great time playing this game I'm going
to give it an 8.5 out of 10 thanks a lot
for watching guys I'm going to be back
with new game reviews very soon today
I'm going to be picking up the new Tomb
Raider game I'm hearing great things
about it thanks a lot for watching guys
and as always if you liked this review
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
[Music]
you